[Musik]
Entschuldigung Karfreitag ist ja
Tanzverbot Sekunde
so Ostern Zeit inne zu halten zu
reflektieren und sich zu fragen hallo
ist hier eigentlich noch jemand hallo
offensichtlich nicht bei den
Kirchenaustritten jagt ein Rekord der
nächsten
360.000 Katholiken sind in nur einem
Jahr ausgetreten und sogar
380.000 Evangelien bei denen sind
erstmals mehr Mitglieder ausgetreten als
verstorben wobei sterben ja auch so eine
Art passiv aggressives austreten ist
wenn die Leute weiter in den Tempo
abhauen haben beide großen Kirchen in 50
bis 60 Jahren keine Gläubigen mehr ja
das ist nicht mehr so lange hin das
passiert noch bevor die Deutsche Bahn
den deutschland-takt einführt
[Gelächter]
reißt euch zusammen verdammt noch mal
ihr braucht Ideen wie ihr die Hütte
wieder voll kriegt ne Imagekampagne
schon Kleinigkeiten können helfen zum
Beispiel mal ein besserer Messwein ich
vertrage Routen nicht so griechisch und
Brennen von ein schöner samion oder wenn
es unbedingt rot sein muss ein Aperol
Spritz
t die Protestanten müssen dringend ein
paar Kirchenlieder kennenzeln wer
ständig da berühren sich Himmel und Erde
oder kleines Senf komm Hoffnung singen
muss bekommt eine Ahnung von der ewigen
Verdammnis und die Katholiken was soll
das mit diesen ständigen extra
Feiertagen
fronleichnamen nicht mal jesus wusste
was von Leichnam ist hier
historische Tatsache ich kann mir auch
irgendwelche Feiertage ausdenken und
sagen da habe ich jetzt frei
das haltet ihr denn von
ist die Kahnfahrt oder maria ihm
schmeckt's nicht apropos Maria wie wäre
es wenn ihr die Frauen in eurem Laden
endlich mal mitmachen lasst jenseits von
Kekse backen fürs Gemeindefest zwei
Drittel aller Katholiken sind laut
Umfragen für Priesterinnen aber die
Brust im Vatikan finden weiter
frauenweihe sei Achtung Wortspiel eine
hodenlose Unverschämtheit
und wie schrieb schon Paulus im Brief an
die mit sogenannten
mitmachen lässt in meine Kirche sollst
du lieber warten bis gar keiner mehr
mitmacht denn er trinkt ein Kamin aus
einer
Menstruationstasse als das eine
Gebärende Gewalt wird
jede Wette wenn irgendwann mal die erste
Frau Priesterin wird kleben sich die
Jungs aus der Chefetage vor der
Kirchentür fest um zu verhindern dass
sie reinkommt
passt die sind ja auch so eine Art
letzte Generation ach was soll's ihr
werdet das auch die nächsten 50 Jahre
nicht schaffen irgendetwas zu ändern ich
sage trotzdem frohe Ostern auch an die
Konfessionslosen und jetzt entschuldige
ich mich ich muss dringend mal austreten
[Musik]
Hicks Markus ibi estitus ja das war
Latein frei übersetzt heißt das glaube
ich jedenfalls abonniert sofort den
Kanal oder es gibt mächtig Ärger